alright John Perry here and it is
Wednesday once again last week was a
really interesting one we got to look at
this
weird alien creature everybody on the
internet was freaking out when this was
first found everybody thought it was
definitely an alien tech people weeks to
kind of calm down and figure out what
this actually was and I was really
impressed with you guys because you
figured it out right away almost all of
you got it right
this was a three-toed sloth the first
person to get that right according to my
count was Hans Olin tle hopefully I just
said your name correctly but he said
three toed sloth it was pretty obvious
once I saw the claws
my reasoning went like this hmm it looks
like it has nipples so it's probably a
mammal pretty long arms oh whoa it's a
slaw he goes on to say some other rather
comical things if you'd like to read
that so yeah congratulations
hans overland tle you have now
officially been write on the Internet
I was really interested in how how easy
it was for everybody to figure this out
but I think that most of you figured
this out simply because you knew that
this should probably be an animal when
this first happened people were really
confused they thought it was an alien or
at least a monster of some kind for a
long time I mean for weeks people were
talking about this on the internet and
Hine said it's really obvious this is a
three-toed sloth it was in Panama where
sloths live it's just a sloth with no
hair by the way a lot of times when
animals get bloated in the water that
their hair can fall out I don't know if
that's the reason this thing was
hairless it might have been sick before
and lost its hair but it is fairly
common for animals to lose their hair
after they die I think it's really
interesting the psychology behind this
now obviously if we were more reasonable
as a species every time we found
something we would first assume that
it's something normal because things
that are common are more common than
things that are uncommon right so if we
were a more reasonable species whenever
we'd find something weird looking like
this the first thing we do is we'd say
huh
I wonder what species I already know of
this might be but there's just something
about you know especially when you see a
dead animal we have this fear reflex
especially a dead bloated animal I would
assume that our phobia of rotting
corpses is
because you know our ancestors that
weren't afraid of rotting corpses maybe
would eat them and get sick or start
poking around and end up getting sick
I could see natural selection giving
rise to a phobia for rotting corpses
we like to validate our fears I don't
feel like our fears are warranted and so
I think that's that's why when we see a
corpse like this we freak out and we
want to just assume that it's an alien
or a monster or something special so in
the future as new monsters come up on
the internet the first time you see them
just think to yourself okay most likely
this is not a monster it might be it
might be an alien from outer space or
something but most likely it's something
common here on earth that is somehow
either deformed or maimed or rotten and
we'll see time and time again that that
that is the case injured or rotting
normal animals so congratulations to
everybody who figured out that that was
indeed a sloth this week's guest is
another bird a really fascinating bird
and aside from having the skull I
actually got for you the talents of this
critter so you can see those as well
here are the talons really awesome look
at this is these are like dragon feet
I love the scales on this extremely
textured feet it's like it's like
sandpaper it's really cool
look at those talons yes it's kind of
gross we just at shin Timoney Wildlife
Center if people send us an animal and
it dies and we have permits to use them
for education
well like cut off their feet and put
them in a fruit dryer and yeah they turn
into these nice little preserved
artifacts like this so notice I have
another skull and another talent behind
here this is for comparison so as a week
five I believe we saw the red-tailed
hawk this is the red-tailed hawk this is
actually a different specimen from week
five
so this is a red-tailed hawk and this is
a red-tailed hawk Talon and when I do
these bird skulls from now on I want to
compare the red tail to whatever it is
that we're we're looking at because the
red tail is a really common bird at
least here in North America and it's
kind of like the standard hawk so I like
to compare other birds to it so you guys
can can do a little bit better and your
your guesses as to what these critters
are so this is the red tail and compare
that to this guy something that I want
to note this has nothing to do I mean
this isn't unique to this specimen but
look inside here this little triangle
this is the ant orbital finestra and
remember we talked about that in week on
week 5 when we looked I think it was
week fired that we talked about it when
we looked at the red-tailed hawk he's
got a little bit of a larger ant orbital
finestra see that spider web-like
structure inside there this guy's got it
too it's actually more easy to see with
this lighting on the red-tailed hawk but
that spiderweb structure inside there
that is the turbinates of a bird and the
turbinates and birds evolved completely
independently from the turbinates in a
mammal and again remember the terminates
the turbinates in a mammal look like
that those structures inside the nose
those are the turbinates and those allow
warm-blooded animals to breathe without
losing moisture moisture from the lungs
when you breathe out your air is the air
that you breathe out is very wet and it
will condense on those turbinates that
moisture will condense on those
turbinates as it's exiting and then when
you breathe in again you'll moisten that
air and bring wet air back to the lungs
so that's one of the main functions of
those turbinates dinosaurs of course
also have a huge ant orbital finestra
much bigger than the specimens
usually in comparison to the other holes
on the skull okay here we have this
week's specimen on top and the red-tail
skull on bottom and you can see that
this weak specimen is a little bit
larger actually let me get you a let's
do a ruler this is something that people
have been requesting so there we have it
in inches and here we have it in
centimeters almost 8 centimeters long
fairly big bird you definitely don't
want to get in a fight with one of these
things they're big enough to hurt you
and though they could use their beak to
hurt you they're more likely to use
their talons look at these monster
talons and we compare this this one on
the left is the red-tailed hawk the one
on the right is the new guy look how
much more rough the scales are on the
bottom of the feet of this larger guy
dragon feet I love it also something
else that's interesting about this this
species is that digit number 4 tone
number 4 can actually move backwards
when it's alive it can't in this because
it's dried the way that it is I wanted
to live it can actually ingest that
backwards or have it forward so it can
have two toes and back two toes and in
the front or gonna have three in the
front one in the back the red-tailed
hawk can't really do that it's just
always three in front one in back what
do you think it is here's the Talon
here's the skull what's it Wednesday all
right
Sophie